huge moment in the Trump Russia
investigation yesterday that isn't
actually part of robert molars Trump
Russia investigation but actually just
related to Russians and Republicans and
the NRA and the 2016 election and this
is a confusing story this story is
confusing a lot of people about what it
means so I want in the interest of
clarity this evening to explain it to
you as clearly as possible
yesterday a 29 year old Russian woman
named Maria boo Tina was charged with
conspiracy to act as an agent of the
Russian Federation in the United States
without prior notification to the
Attorney General what does this mean in
layman's terms a Russian person was in
the US as an agent of Russia officially
but didn't register as such this is
similar to what other people involved in
the Trump Russia investigation have been
accused of which is working for foreign
governments without being registered
agents for those governments and the
general the complaint form from the
Justice Department alleges quote the
court filings detailed the Russian
officials and boo Tina's efforts for boo
Tina to act as an agent of Russia inside
the United States by developing
relationships with US persons and
infiltrating organizations having
influence in American politics for the
purpose of advancing the interests of
the Russian Federation the filings also
describe certain actions taken by boo
Tina to further this effort during
multiple visits from Russia and later
when she entered and resided in the
United States on a student visa the
filings alleged that she undertook her
activities without officially disclosing
the fact that she was acting as an agent
of Russian government as required by law
the next question is who was she meeting
with and hopefully we will learn that
but the story is made even better
because a video has been uncovered from
2015 where the same woman Maria boo Tina
actually asks now president Donald Trump
a question at an event called Freedom
Fest and it gets even better than that
because in his answer Trump says
he knows Putin and this was 2015 it was
before Trump had subsequently denied
knowing Vladimir Putin it is yet another
time that Trump seems to be caught in
that lie whatever the truth was at the
time
check out this stunning video of this
woman who was just indicted talking to
Donald Trump at Freedom Fest politics
relationships with my country and do you
want to continue the politics of
assumptions that the damage in Nepal's
economy or you have any other ideas okay
Obama gets along with nobody the whole
world hates us you know it's an amazing
thing you look at Mexico they hate us
they hate our leadership and yet they're
making a fortune China hates us China is
building ports in the South China Sea we
could never do a thing like that because
we'd have to get environmental impact
statements okay so we're
I jokingly said to a friend if they got
an environmental impacts they have been
what they did so China
hates us and yet they're making it
everybody hates us and yet they make
money with us with me we're gonna make
money on them and they're gonna like
this
I know button and I'll tell you what we
get along with hood Putin has no respect
for President Obama big problem big
problem and Russia has been driven yeah
I've always heard for years I've heard
one of the worst things that can happen
to our country is if Russia ever gets
driven to China we have driven them
together with the big oil deal set up
England Wow and Trump says in the same
video
he would probably lift sanctions on
Putin because he just wouldn't need them
okay and I mean when we have the
strength I don't think you need the
sanctions I think that we would get
along very very well stunning
truly truly stunning what's going on and
once again I want to say this a second
time because it's important this is not
part of the Moller investigation this is
a totally separate investigation so
consider the advancement here we had
Americans indicted Michael Flynn Paul
Manafort but the idea was they didn't do
stuff directly with Russia during the
campaign then we had Russians indicted
but they were in Russia doing cyber
meddling they weren't here in the United
States doing stuff in person we now have
a Russian working on the behalf of the
Russian government
in the United States without disclosing
that they are working as an agent of
Russia who's accused of infiltrating
organizations that have influence on
American politics specifically to
advance Russian interests and if you
look at the affidavit in support of
these charges they're pretty ominous
because they include references to both
the political party apparently the
Republican Party and a gun gun rights
organization likely the NRA and that's a
link that we've been tracking for month
quote on October 4 2016 us person 1 sent
an email to an acquaintance the email
covered a number of topics within the
email us person once stated unrelated to
specific presidential campaigns I've
been involved in securing a very private
line of communication between the
Kremlin and
key political party one leaders through
of all conduits the gun rights
organization which is redacted this is
stunning and it builds even more because
remember those reports we did on the
link between Russia and Trump and the
NRA this is at least the Russia NRA
component we have a picture of Maria
butene opposing at NRA headquarters with
the NRA president at the time David
Keene
here she is with NRA s Wayne LaPierre in
a picture we are showing our television
audience here she is with senator Rick
Santorum another big NRA advocate also
pictured with Louisiana Governor Bobby
Jindal a big gun guy this is a treasure
trove and the story is building daily
and it is yet another one of these
stories from months ago which we've been
covering Russia funneling money through
the NRA to Donald Trump pieces are
falling into place every single day if
not week more and more pieces fall into
place and now we have an actual Russian
indicted for actions within the United
States
what will we know in two weeks Pat that
is the question I think we're gonna know
a lot discuss this with us on our
subreddit
at david pakman.com slash our IDI di t
quick break luke vargas joins us next
from helsinki he's not just there
hanging out he was there for the trunk
putin summit and i've got a lot of
questions for luca coming up next
today's program is sponsored in part by
Blink accom slash Pakman if you've not
already heard about blinka s-- it's
amazing it's an app for your phone
tablet or web browser and what they do
is they take nonfiction books popular
nonfiction critically acclaimed
nonfiction they condense the book into a
fifteen minute audio book you get all
the most important information and
insights from each book but you can soak
up the entire essence of the book in one
sitting I've listened to a ton of books
on blinkin recent one is a Robert Rice's
new book the common
good also bunk by Kevin Young useful in
preparing me for the pseudoscience
miniseries that we're producing and if
you are a david pakman show viewer or
listener you can get a seven day free
trial by going to blink is comm slash
Pakman if you're watching on youtube use
the link in the video description
after the free trial if you like it you
can get the full access to thousands of
condensed audiobooks for about five
bucks a month that's be li NK is t.com
/pa ke ma n